i did an audition i still remember the
dance and here's how it goes
yourself at
with
home
this is sweet right so the fans because
the fans who go to do it
they then of course want to blog about
it because they've had this amazing
experience
but when they blog about it it's
borderline confusing on whether they had
a good time
or not so here are some of the blog
things
so we were asked to go to the living
room sit down not know how much i was
sweating during that moment
i was like the [ __ ] is going to happen
i could not keep up then all of a sudden
she just pops out of nowhere she
appeared out of thin air like david
copperfield
and we all died like for real
wait there's more
this one so she said she'll be playing
her album for us let me tell you the
noise thinking out of my mouth was not
human
i legit almost told mama swift to call
me an ambulance because i wasn't going
to make it
i love them so much because they always
talk about dying
you're like rest in peace me alright me
i died dead we took a little break we
did a little break and she was passing
around rice crispy treats and cookies
and i was talking to her mom for a
little and then i walked back in and she
was like hey babe thanks for coming do
you want to treat and i was like i would
but i think i'm dead
this is this is oh this is well anyway
we were given the keys to the wrong room
and walked into the room to find a naked
african gentleman washing his genitals
in the sink
are you whispering all of the extra did
you did
1980
you're not rachel from friends and yet
whatever you do to your hair it becomes
a thing
yeah it does believe it or not yeah so
do you have something
you would have been really bad did you
do you think ahead do you kind of go
but i don't no i don't there's certain
ones that i've just done just off the
cuff
so there's no shame in some of them
before any of the hipsters are doing it
ashamed of any of them well you should
be ashamed of some of them
but before any of the hipsters were
doing it you had the top knot
there you go lovely that's always a
practical thing that's not bad yeah no
it's fine
it's fine this one okay what was going
on here
yeah that was that was maybe a bad
decision
it was a bad timing as well because i
was actually going to
south africa at the time with england
and i ended
up meeting uh nelson mandela i know you
did and
and the pictures
that was the entire night now had you
planned
the loose strand
no it kind of just fell that way just
felt that yeah
i mean it looks lovely it looks lovely
it works but it triggers fear
melt down about this hair here's just a
selection of some of the tweets that
they
have zane single strand of hair is
prettier than my entire face
we haven't seen the person it could be
true
it's another one zayn's hair is the
reason
uh what what's next what's that i love
this satan's hair tonight
is why i still believe in miracles
this this is genius this is you someone
was just so
moved all they could treat was this
i want to strangle myself
just going through your head then when
they had the pool party
at the beginning your wife won't bring
up old [ __ ]
because you want to know i took my
clothes
but we do have a photograph
now had you annoyed someone er
why haven't they done that to you well
because i want to be up there and see
all these there's a million bats there
you see
and i wanted to be there when all the
bats were coming out of the cave so i
could say something like uh
that's a million bats coming out of here
so here's the so just this is just uh
this isn't scientific
so how many women here so shout out how
many women here have read the books
yes okay and how many men have read the
books
is there one where's the man who read it
there show yourself
did you read have you really read the
books did you enjoy them no they're
shocked
i used to have old styles of taking
pictures
you know i tried i tried a couple things
i'll show you how i used to so
so one of my first ones was the the you
know when i was young
it was the pelvic lead you know so this
was how i used to take
pictures with all the fans and then i
felt like this wasn't
you know yeah it's not appropriate right
no i feel uncomfortable you feel
uncomfortable
you feel good i'm the fans
who's revolicious then um oh that's like
when i sometimes pretend to have a rap
alter ego
i'm like you know that my name is
rubblicious respect
i'm not that crazy doesn't everyone like
have a rap alter ego yeah
what's yours warm
what would yours be um be still yeah
he actually did that was ready thank you
that was ready you wrapped as well
i did uh when i was like 14 i did a bar
mitzvah rap
do you remember any of your wraps rebel
uh well we only used to do covers
uh because that's what legit rappers do
you usually do a lot of like crisscross
salt and pepper
you know all that if i played a little
bit of do you know push it would you not
push it
all right let me give it a go oh do you
want a microphone look i've got a
microphone look at everything
all right
yeah okay so i'll just start the music
yep
right
well look at there's two things about
that one they're in an adult situation
so if they don't like my language
then don't [ __ ] show up
i loved the lion king when i was younger
and i had a weird obsession with nala
look at her face she's so sweet